好 其实股市有众多利空来交杂着淬炼
它就比较容易形成底部和过关
我们刚刚讲到总经面
当然这个礼拜有很多的事情
但AI科技发展也有很多的事情
这边要来请教汉伟哥了
什么事情呢
Ensopic就讲说
如果AI再发展下去
可能他们会往消灭人类的部分去走
怎么会这么恐怖
那OpenAI说今年的上市计划
IPO计划大概是没有了
要到明年期市场有点担心
發生什麼事
那另外剛剛施工有提到
其實戰火還在打
紅海還在封
那這邊的話航海往後續
就很有機會在戰爭裡面
繼續往上走
對 所以我覺得今天這個
所謂AI雜音應該是
今天盤面上日股 雅股
甚至說美股大跌的主要原因
那到底發生什麼事情
我覺得就在禮拜天
這NZOFIC的執行長阿莫迪
他說他看到AI已經有
脫離他們控制的一個趨勢
然後超級AI可能在3年會誕生
一旦诞生的话
可能有人类灭亡的一个危机
讲着这样是怎样
对 但他一向以来都是这种
AI末日论的一个爱好者
只是说他一边喊末日
一边他的模型是发展的最快的
所以有一点点我觉得是商业的考量
为什么这样讲
因为他希望说整个产业放慢
最先进的模型开发速度
叫别人先不要就对了
因为他又挂牌了嘛
别人如果太快
他可能挂牌比较不好
然后再来就说他刚刚提到
AI的安全的能力
但他就说
那你可以用我的模型
我已经先加了一些限制
然后再来我觉得这一招最狠
他建议所有在开发AI模型的人
都要导入独立的第三方安全评估机制
他说现在它已经
Enthropic已经开放
政府可以派员来检查它的一个原始代码
那就代表你所有对手要开发
你全部都给政府看光光
所以如果它跟政府关系好的话
它是不是可以知道别人的进度
所以这件事情
其实是在阻碍整个其他竞争对手的发展
那但是你会发现到
奧特曼跟馬斯克也同步戰勝說
我們看起來我覺得這個AI
也有可能會造成人類的滅亡
哎呦
所以就是
葫蘆裡賣什麼藥
三巨頭同樣講這件事情
大家覺得好像三人成虎
聽起來就是這麼一回事了
所以今天你看到牌面上會大跌
我覺得主要原因就是來說
因為大家開始擔心
如果真的大家都去做一個降速
那待會未來就可以
很合理的去降低你的資本支出
對
所以整個供應鏈就會出現這種
期望過高的失望性賣壓
尤其這資本支出
最大的一個大頭在回答
所以今天晚上回答
股價就非常重要了
我們看川普他說了什麼
他說你這些看空AI的人
是負面的勢力
對 他說誰贏了AI誰就贏
你不要忘了這個月
還有什麼川席會
所以目前中國
沒有受到美國限制
如果你美國自綁手腳
讓中國的AI往上串出
變領先的話
我覺得對於美國競爭力
造成影響
所以我們總結來講
我覺得這個看起來是這三個巨頭
他們開始擔心有一些後進者的追擊
所以看起來有些聯合
希望制定一個所謂的AI的標準
來限制後面模型的發展
那這個我覺得當然大家可能就是
短相會造成盤面上的影響
但中長線還是看到
資本如果繼續漲的話
我覺得對於台灣或是全球的AI
應該不會造成太大的衝擊
好 他有一點耳於我詐
但是川普站在這個制高點就會說
大家還是給我乖乖發展
不要講那麼多
對 因為他的很大的一個政見美國投資者投資AI你一旦說錢的話川普可能就不用選了好 那我們來看到接下來我們講今天記憶體也有一些所謂利空消息又同樣的鬼故事來了
不要用那麼多了
對 因為CMX上出一個報告
它簡單去講就是說
它認為在下一代
VR-Rubin的一個進階版
它可能所謂的
記憶體的HBM4的堆疊
會以8成然後降到4成
是
它上一個報告
我記得6月份的時候說
從12成降到8成
然後現在8成再降到4成
對 8成再降到4成
那为什么有这样的情况
其实我觉得
这个报告内容跟上一次讲的一样
因为相关的HBN太缺货了
所以如果说你坚持要12层的堆叠的话
你后面可能产量会
产量会明显的
就是供应链的瓶颈会变得比较高
所以如果说把12拆成4
你可能本来出一台变出三台
所以对于整个供应链的顺畅来讲
挥达也觉得这样看起来还不错
另外一个你可以发现到
上个礼拜我们刚刚讲到
联准会升息
但美股反而利空不跌大涨
但美股的基底在上礼拜
我就已經先跌了
是
因為傳出來
Diskic 發了一個新的
V4.1 Flash 的一個模型
是
他說如果用它的模型的話
HPM 需求只要減少
降低到四分之一就夠了
原本大概就是四顆
你現在只要一顆
那如果 SAD 硬碟的話
降到八分之一
看起來就是你不用用到
那麼多的記憶容量
就可以運氣它的一個模型
所以聽起來非常的好
今年三月大家如果還有記得
那個 Google 出了一個論文說
Turbo Quant
它的用量只要六分之一
但後面的記憶體
大家發現到需求還會成長
所以我覺得對於記憶體來講
應該是短線的雜音
但股價線形不好
我們待會看一下線形
所以你看到今天盤面上
如果以這些跟AI相關的族群當中
都有鬼故事
但因為記憶鬼故事比較多
所以今天跌比較重一些
那阿克華碗店都是重挫
大概半根停板左右
阿力基電因為跟聯電
有聯動的關係
所以相對抗疊
但你看到散熱
IC設計跟伺服器
今天我覺得比較亮眼
在所謂細智材這個區塊
細智材 對
對 因為大家會聯想會轉單
那這些公司我覺得
其實基本面都沒有太大問題
基本來講都是年月雙征
或說歷史新高或歷史次高
代表AI的需求的
基本面是非常好的
但看現行會發生到
不一樣的一個感覺
好 我們南亞科還是世界最強嗎
我剛剛還問了漢偉哥
漢偉哥說沒有
現在跟美光差不多了
對 因為美光
最近好不容易跑到季線之上
我們接近季線了
對 所以我們變成說
南雅科有點事業最常在補跌
對 那補跌到季線附近
跟三星 跟海域市 跟美光差不多了
所以接下來大家可能就看一下
因為它目前我覺得大致上就維持
這個相形區間的一個整理
因為是量縮回跌嘛
但大富是站在買方
外資算有點做一些調節的動作
但如果我覺得接下來
在這個月底還有一個大事情
就是美光公布財報
所以美光股價其實大家如果去看
上禮拜的美光
其實它接近到快要轉強的一個態勢
所以我覺得如果今天往美光
盤後盤看來是續跌的
如果美光也回遮到基線關卡
那我覺得到基線附近
如果你對它這種短線上
要做區間招勢的話
可以做一個考慮低階的動作
但如果你手上有的
基本上來講
從低檔到買上來到高檔破線
其實應該要做一個部分的
獲利了結的動作
所以我覺得南亞科現階段
當然它是擔負了
台灣記憶體的一個領頭羊
那陷阱既然它回到基線附近
代表整個記憶體
目前線形都偏弱
所以如果要操作記憶體的話
最少納尔科要回到軍線之上
我覺得台灣記憶體的一個
人氣跟所謂的動能才會回來
那你看到今天盤面上
齊鴻就比較強勁了
對 因為他業績也非常好
那當然大家會覺得說同樣也會受到AI需求的影響但齊鴻畢竟他是做水冷散熱的嘛那現階段你說的 AI 製造中心還是需要水冷散熱
所以可能是未來的影響性會有
但短暗來看我覺得市場選擇
我都已經修正到這邊了
有一些技術面的支撐
那就從馬來看的話
你可以看到它相對比較好
三大反基本上都有同步站在買方
所以我覺得就現行角度來看
齊鴻只要月線不被跌破
那散熱股的話
就會維持一個多方的輪動
今天算是族群当中
高利跌算是比较重一点
应该本预比较高
但是不管是双红 建策 齐红
目前我觉得都还算是
稳健的一个标的
那我们再看到下一个
这个两个重点个股
好 创意今天是创历史新高
真的是逆势图
还有一些IP股
今天表现也都不差
对 那我觉得市场就联想到
如果接下来这些所谓的
三巨头要砍单的话
先砍 挥打
好 是这样的联想
所以今天晚上挥打的股价
真的要观察起来
對 因為輝達他下一代的賣點
就是他新一代的這個模型
會用到更高階的一個
不管是CPU相關的一些
AI的基礎建設
那如果說大家要暫緩資本支出的話
我就先看輝達的單
那我們就選擇這個
CP值比較高的
自研晶片 ASIC 的部分
所以創作我覺得社會上的題材
兼股價反而逆勢走高
創作率是新高
那他能夠創作率是新高的話
代表IC社會族群
剛剛其實永遠老師也提到的
聯發科現行也表現不錯
所以整個IC社會族群
目前來看我覺得
跟矽子台相關的
也許在短線上
如果看到灰達跌的話
他們會有一些資金的一個
轉單效應的期待性
目前來看
不管是外資投信都在買方
大戶也在買方
現行既然創高的話
我覺得你就不用去追高啦
但是有回到月線附近的話
對 可以考慮做一個逢低的成接
這波反彈是漲一倍囉
從3100到6500了
好驚人
那好處是在來說
今天是有帶量
而且它整理完之後
再往上走高
所以應該是還有
再往上的一波
但毕竟这个已经
本益比较高了
所以你追高我觉得是有风险的
同样一个伪创
它的形态看起来就比较不好看了
对 那我觉得伪创
第一个就是这个
违影它的这个除旋席的行情
不是非常好
没有 它要解决那个基因股
也有做一些解决了
但大家小股民抱怨不断
对 那我觉得大部分有点就是
大家要去拿它的分拆股票
所以之前已经拉得太高了
所以分拆完之后可能大家觉得
那我就賣個其中分掉一張股票
也是
對 就讓股價偏弱
所以目前這個微銀股價
有點拖累到偽創
但我們發現到上個禮拜五
還沒有發生AI 滾伏之前
戴爾電腦
然後惠普電腦
跟惠語科技
這三檔AI伺服器美股當中
都創造率率性高
所以對於台灣的組裝代工來講
我覺得算是委屈了
因為台灣目前
整理之代最好是偽創
對
你看到鴻海跟廣達
都在季線附近進行整理
所以我覺得目前反而
如果你要去找一個比較安全的
台灣AI股的話
我覺得AI儲裝代工
既然美股已經先創高了
也許他們接下來是有機會的
好 這個主持人也說
就會突然之間來一段
不蹲點的話還真抓不到
對 那我們接下來看到這個
就是大家覺得
那AI股數那麼多的話
要不要做一些所謂資金的
所謂分散風險
那我們會跟大家講就是說
大家可以注意到
最近所謂的中東的局勢
還是非常緊張
油價已經來到
布蘭特 謝德州
都來到100美元一桶以上
主要原因其實就是在於說
因為現在除了這個
荷姆茲海峽已經被封鎖了
現在連所謂的曼德海峽
都被這個葉門的叛軍奪取了
那再來講說基本面的部分你看到SCFI的一個指數是連續七週的上漲對 那上漲的部分美東美西創波段新高那甚至我們看到當中報價東南亞航線 亞洲航線 近海航線
都創造近期的波段高點
那唯一比較弱是在歐洲航線的部分
漲幅是比較落後的
但我覺得整體上來看代表說
目前運價是在上漲的
那大家會覺得運價上漲
對於整個航運股有沒有激烈的作用
因為航海王量還沒有出來
但我們來看它國際的指標股
的指標股
好 馬士基
真的是蠻強的
已經創下2022年以來的
歷史新高了
對 因為我想說
台灣的老水手在過去
很愛追蹤什麼
SYPY運價
然後很愛去追蹤
馬士基 赫伯羅德
已經航運看過報價
對
就有點類似你現在看
記憶體三星 海力士
跟美光的情況
那你看到馬士基
股價到今天下午盤
是創下2022年來的新高
那代表說
它其實再往上的話
是有機會挑戰歷史新高的
那日本如果注意到
像日本遊船 川崎汽船
他們在大概我記得八月份的時候
都穿到歷史新高
所以整個全球的航運股 航運指數
甚至我們台灣的航運相關ETF
其實表現都不錯
所以在這樣的環境當中
既然有國際龍頭股已經創高了
加上說運價轉強
所以台灣的航運股
我覺得今天盤面上比較無恩
是因為量太小了
今天成交量因為6000多億
可能照顧不了那麼多族群
可是剛剛看到運價
其實是不停的上漲
國際的航運股也在上漲
對 所以我覺得他們因為
大部分股本比較偏大
所以還是要一些量能回來
所以會有點像說
你要做資金的分散
你不能全壓航運股
因為電子股轉強的話
你就覺得好像沒有參與到行情
但如果說你現在覺得
電子股的一個
很多的消息面
覺得有點擔心的話
我覺得航運股反而成資金的避風感
那你看到其實航運股
其實營收都出來了
8月營收所有運價上漲
都創造近期的新高
那我們看現行的話會發生到
我覺得兩張股票可以留意啦
比較活潑的貨櫃航空就選擇萬海
因為剛剛看到SCF
東南亞航線等等
我覺得運價漲幅還蠻大的
那股價上次講完之後
是漲了一波下來之後
那回測到月線關卡
月線還是上彎的
我覺得今天看起來試圖
要站回到月線以上
如果回到月線再突破這高點
就符合回後買上漲
那可能就有機會重新挑戰
這個波段的一個高點
好 他有跟我說
8月17號有說
大戶很早就卡位在航運股
大戶真的比我們有耐心敢蹲點
其實真的要蹲點
不然這樣每天漲
追著會怕怕的
對 那我們覺得上次回來之後
再回黨
我覺得現在以這個盤面上
量數環境帶你不用嘴鎬
你可以縫拉回去介入
但以目前運價跟紅海的局勢的話
我覺得應該後續有空間
那另外一檔就是行星
大家如果注意到最近
所謂的中東局勢緊張之後
有很多掛這個伊朗級的郵輪
被擊沉了
所以全球能夠做郵輪運輸的船隻
大幅減少
那台灣唯一有郵輪就是行星
它有三招邮轮
所以我觉得就有点这种
邮价带动的运价上涨
那大家发现到
现在每一桶原有100多美元当中
大概有十几块美元是
这个邮轮的运价
所以我觉得对新银来讲
它反而就有后续的想象空间
因为供给变少了嘛
那现今一段它股价也是一样
这一波沿着月线
上去之后回到月线附近
那量能这边萎缩回到月线
我觉得是合理的
大户重新在在买方
外资在买方
我觉得如果说大家担心
电子股的波动很大的话
像這兩檔整理完之後
再轉牆的
我覺得都可以特別留意
好 不知道我們聽著聽著
就覺得跑船真的好辛苦
就是越是地緣政治的混亂
他們反而可能運駕越好
可是其實船員們是更辛苦的
對 有人生風險
好 這邊非常謝謝浩瑋哥